if we want to go back and ask the
question when
was donald trump first contagious for
coronavirus the answer is
actually a very scary one because it
likely
was during the debate with joe biden
on tuesday fortunately so far joe biden
has had
uh it's either two or three negative
coronavirus tests and it's probably
another day or two before he would
be completely out of the woods due to
the incubation time during which you
would not yet test positive but what we
do know are the following first of all
donald trump lied about his tests when
donald trump was interviewed on the sean
hannity program thursday night at 9 00
pm eastern
9 or 10 i believe 9 pm might be 10 p.m
that was before his 1am announcement of
testing positive he said i've been
tested and i'm waiting for the results
but in reality
donald trump had already had a positive
rapid test at that time he had had a
positive test
and was waiting on results from a second
pcr
test trump already had a positive test
but pretended that he had not
then donald trump's doctor talked on
saturday morning
said we're 72 hours in which puts us at
wednesday morning
and then later the doctor said no no no
i misspoke that's not true but already
very weird
and then fox news's chris wallace who
was the debate moderator last tuesday
between donald trump and joe biden said
well
you know how everybody was tested at the
debate hall
well turns out trump wasn't really
tested trump showed up late
and we went on the honor system that he
had tested negative
check this out was that i arrived on
sunday i think you arrived on monday
they didn't arrive till tuesday
afternoon so
for them to get tested uh there wouldn't
have been enough time
to have the test and have the debate at
nine o'clock that night they didn't show
up
until three four five o'clock in the
afternoon so
yeah there was an honor system when it
came to the people that came into the
hall from the two campaigns
so in reality trump might have been
positive
at that time and known it so they
deliberately showed up late to avoid the
test but
even without that idle speculation
there's a bigger reality
according to dr ashish jha dean of the
brown university school of public health
based on the timeline that they admit to
trump likely was infected between
saturday
and monday that points to the amy coney
barrett
super spreader event i'm talking about
not this previous saturday but the one
before it
takes five days on average for the virus
to be detected from the point of view of
an infection
and then it can remain detectable for up
to 14 days
with some exceptions on average
coronavirus remains
undetected for around five days
after the point of infection which means
that
trump likely was infected and
likely contagious on tuesday although
fortunately as far as at least on stage
he didn't go near joe biden
and indeed so far joe biden has tested
negative multiple times
after the debate chris wallace was also
on stage with them and he says he will
get tested
but is waiting because his doctor told
him early on
you could get a false negative take a
look at what chris wallace had to say
minutes uh you've got some people
testing positive
senator mike lee who we've learned was
at the white house
earlier this week can you maybe umbrella
all of this for us with what we should
be watching for
well i'm going to tell you what my
doctor is telling me
which raises some some questions for me
and you know i
i'm only going to tell you what my
doctor is telling me but it does
raise some questions about the timeline
because i'm gonna have to get a test
i'm in a uh uh in a uniquely
vulnerable circle the three people on
the stage for an extended period with
the president
and the vice president and me all
without masks
uh and and my doctor is telling me that
i shouldn't get a test today
because it takes five days for the virus
to load up
enough and that i could have a test but
it might well be a false negative
the significance of that to me is that
if the president had a test yesterday
uh and it tested positive then i think
he had the coronavirus
during the debate because you know this
talk about well he was with hope hicks
on the plane
in minnesota on wednesday i don't think
you'd have a positive test and again i'm
not a doctor i'm simply telling it in
terms of what
i was told by my doctor uh you it
wouldn't load up enough to have a
definitive positive test uh on
for about four or five days which is why
i'm not getting tested until next monday
so chris wallace actually making
absolute and total sense here now why is
chris wallace in a studio saying this
shouldn't wallace also be quarantining
if he may have been exposed
and has not yet had a negative test just
asking but
overall it is a trail of incompetence
and chaos that follows donald trump
his actions and decisions and behaviors
are disastrous
everywhere he goes and this actually
makes trump's criticism of joe biden
during the debate for wearing a mask a
big mask
it makes it even more immoral and
ridiculous remember this
i don't have i don't wear mess like him
every time you see him he's got a mask
he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
well we now know that at the same time
that donald trump was laughing at chris
at
uh joe biden for wearing a big mask
and having small crowds at his events
and so on and so forth in all likelihood
donald trump was contagious at that time
how insane is this situation and we've
better hope
that joe biden does not end up testing
positive it it again
it doesn't chris wallace announced at
the start of the debate the candidates
have agreed
not to shake hands at the end of the
debate they did not approach each other
at one point it sort of seemed like
donald trump was going to approach joe
biden and if you watch that moment again
you can't really tell but it's possible
that melania trump held him back
who knows what melania trump knew at the
time about trump's coronavirus status
because they won't answer questions such
as
when was trump's latest negative test
they won't tell us kaylee mcinanny has
said she's not going to tell us
because of privacy reasons if you can
imagine we simply do not know
and are left to speculate how insane is
this situation
let's talk a little bit more about chris
wallace now